easier but first I'd like to address
Russia's missile attacks on Ukraine this
week
on the very day that I and others
confronted the Russian foreign minister
across the G20 Summit table with the
brutality of his country's actions on
the very day that President zielinski
addressed the G20 with a plan to stop
the war
Russia launched over 80 separate missile
strikes on Ukraine
the targets were innocent people and
civilian infrastructure the AIM to cast
the population Into Darkness and cold
once again Russia has shown its
barbarity and given the lie to any claim
that they are interested in peace during
the bombardment of Ukraine on Tuesday an
explosion took place in eastern Poland
the investigation into this incident is
ongoing and it has our full support
as we have heard the Polish and American
Presidents say it is possible that the
explosion was caused by a Ukrainian
munition which was deployed in
self-defense
and whether or not this proves to be the
case no blame can be placed on a country
trying to defend itself against such a
barrage
the blame belongs solely to Russia
I spoke to president Duty yesterday to
express my sympathy and pledge our
solidarity I also spoke to president
zielinski on a joint call with prime
minister Trudeau to express our
continued support and I met my G7 and
NATO counterparts at the sidelines of
the G20
we will help our polish allies to
conclude their investigation and we will
continue to stand with Ukraine in the
face of Russia's criminal aggression Mr
Speaker the Bali Summit took place
amidst the worst global economic crisis
since 2008.
the G20 was created to grip challenges
like this but today's crisis is
different
because it has been driven by a G20
member by turning off the gas Taps and
choking off the Ukrainian grain Supply
Russia has severely disrupted Global
Food and energy markets
the economic shock waves will Ripple
around the world for years to come
so together with other responsible
members of the G20 we are delivering a
decisive response almost all G20 members
called out Russia's actions declaring
that today's era must not be one of War
we will work together to uphold
international law and the United Nations
Charter
and we will act to protect our
Collective Economic Security the G20
agreed to use all available tools to
support the global economy and ensure
Financial stability
that means International financial
institutions mobilizing more resources
to support developing countries it means
continuing to call out those who exploit
their lending power to create debt traps
for emerging economies and it means
tackling the causes of rising inflation
head-on including by delivering fiscal
sustainability
we pledged our support for the UN
brokered deal to keep grain shipments
moving in the Black Sea
that deal I'm pleased to say has now
been renewed two-thirds of Ukraine's
wheat goes to developing countries
with famine looming it is desperately
needed and Russia must uphold its part
of this deal we agreed action to improve
energy security by accelerating the
transition to clean energy and we
launched a new Just Energy transition
partnership with Indonesia which will
unlock billions in private Finance for
new green energy infrastructure
and finally we committed to maintain
free markets free trade and to reform
the World Trade Organization
Mr Speaker yesterday I held my first
meeting with President Biden we pledged
to redouble our support for Ukraine and
to continue deepening our cooperation
including on energy security and
managing the challenges posed by China
I met Prime Minister Modi where we
reviewed progress on our forthcoming FTA
I discussed our extension to the cptpp
with the prime ministers of Japan Canada
and Australia
and I met with almost every other leader
at the summit with the exception of
Russia
in each of these discussions there was a
shared determination to restore
stability deliver long-term growth and
drive a better future
one where no single country has the
power to hold us back
in just a few moments my right Uncle
friend the chancellor will build on
these International foundations when he
sets out the Autumn statement putting
our economy back onto a positive
trajectory and restoring our fiscal
sustainability
by being strong abroad we strengthen our
resilience at home so we will continue
to support Ukraine we will continue to
stand up for the rule of law and the
fundamental principles of sovereignty
and self-determination
and we will build a global economy that
is more secure more stable and more
resilient because this is what the
gravity of the moment demands and this
is how we will ensure that our country
emerges from this crisis stronger than
it was before and I commend this
statement to the house I know it's all
the leader of the opposition
uh thank you Mr Speaker I'd like to
thank the Prime Minister for advanced
copy of his statement what should have
been a summit focused on global economic
recovery and delivering clear
commitments on climate change was sadly
overshadowed by the unjustifiable
actions of Russia and their illegal war
in Ukraine civilian infrastructure
targeted across Ukraine and a war of
aggression rumbling on as world leaders
tried to reach agreement
whatever the outcome of the
investigation into the missile incident
in Poland it is a stark reminder of the
danger Russia's unjustifiable War has
brought to the border of our NATO allies
we must remain Vigilant and United in
our opposition to this pointless and
brutal conflict and as I've said many
times from this dispatch box and to the
antonyms to personally whatever other
differences we may have across this
house and there are many when it comes
to the defense of Ukraine we stand as
one
[Music]
and on behalf of members on this side of
house well across the house I want to
send condolences to those killed in
Poland
Poland's measured reaction to the
incident and the calm heads that have
prevailed over the past two days is
welcome and listen carefully to what the
Prime Minister said about this and agree
with him that no country can be blamed
for defending itself
we do need to get to the bottom of this
and obviously the investigation is
ongoing but can I ask the Prime Minister
when he expects those investigations to
be finalized
Russia is losing this war so I welcome
the g20s communique which set out that
most members strongly condemned the war
in Ukraine
and I asked the Prime Minister has
further support for Ukraine been
discussed amongst Western allies and
what efforts are taking place to open a
diplomatic road map to rid Ukraine of
Russian troops and bring an end to the
conflict
it is crucial we work to find
International Unity to further isolate
Putin
that will include working with China
we do not underestimate the challenges
China poses to Global Security
and we must defend the human rights of
the uyghur and democracy in Hong Kong
but our approach must be measured and it
is in our interests to work with China
on the climate crisis trade and most
importantly isolating Putin
I was glad to see constructive Dialogue
on these issues between President Biden
and president XI and I'd like to ask the
Prime Minister if he believes this
Summit marks a change in western China
relations
and whether his government is now taking
a different approach from his
predecessor to British China relations
Mr Speaker after a decade of low growth
in this country it's crucial we open new
trade opportunities prime minister
assert he met Prime Minister Modi where
a future UK India trade deal was
discussed
this deal has previously been put in
doubt by his Home Secretary indicating
she would not support it
labor does support a trade deal with
India we believe this can bring new
opportunities to promote and create new
jobs here in Britain so can he tell us
when he now expects this deal to be
completed and if measures on visas will
be included in the overall deal and if
so could he guarantee his whole
government will actually support it
can he also tell us whether in his
meeting with President Biden the UK U.S
trade deal was discussed or can we
assume that this deal now has no
Prospect of being delivered anytime soon
lastly Mr Speaker can I ask the Prime
Minister whether the Northern Ireland
protocol was raised by either U.S or EU
colleagues
failure to make progress is hurting
British research development and trade
all at a time when we need to remove
barriers for British business
fixing this issue could lead to a better
relationship with our biggest trading
partners an opportunity for our
scientists and our exporters
an end to the past two years of
unnecessary fights and division so when
is he going to deliver
Mr Speaker our International alliances
have never been so crucial for global
stability and our own stability
we on this side of the house know that
standing up to Russia's aggression will
require further sacrifice
but we must make those sacrifices
because taking no action is not an
option
the message from all of us must be clear
Ukraine will win
and Putin will lose democracy and
Liberty will defeat imperialism again
thank you Mr Speaker
[Applause]
well Mr Speaker can I start by thanking
the right honorable gentleman for his uh
words about the situation in Ukraine and
Russia and for his condemnation of the
Russian aggression and steadfast support
for the government and indeed this whole
House's position on Ukraine uh he's
right to ask about the further support
that we'll be providing he'll know that
we have provided one and a half billion
pounds in economic and humanitarian
support to Ukraine alongside obviously
the military assistance we are hosting a
reconstruction conference in the UK next
year and there's an ongoing dialogue
about what further support that the
Ukrainian government needs from us and
others in the short term we are in the
process of providing 25
000 pieces of winter equipment for the
brave Ukrainian soldiers but also
funding to help restore some of the
Damage Done to their energy
infrastructure which I know has been
warmly welcomed by President zielinski
I'd just to briefly turn to some of his
other questions uh on China I very much
supported President Biden in his meet
meeting with President XI we discussed
the president and I discussed that
meeting at length I believe that our
approach to China is aligned entirely
with that of the US and indeed our other
allies like Canada and Australia of
course China poses significant
challenges to our values our interests
and indeed our Economic Security it's
right that we take the steps necessary
to defend ourselves against them but it
is also right to engage in dialogue
where that can make a difference on
solving some of the pressing Global
challenges that we all collectively face
he asked about the Northern Ireland I
have discussed this issue with both my
European counterparts and indeed the
president in various meetings not just
at the G20 I remain committed to finding
a solution to the challenges posed by
the protocol it is clearly having an
impact on families and businesses on the
ground in Northern Ireland the people of
Northern Ireland deserve to have a
functioning executive particularly at a
time like this and it's something that I
will devote my energies to Bringing
about and I've had so far very
constructive relationships with both the
president and our European counterparts
including the t-shock last week on this
particular issue on trade I think my the
broad the broad overarching comment I
would make to him is when it comes to
trade deals whoever they may be with
what I won't do is sacrifice quality for
Speed I think it is important I think it
is important
I think it is important that we take the
time it is important it is important
that we take the time to get trade deals
right of course this government believes
wholeheartedly in the power and the
benefits of free trade it's something
that we will Champion around the world
uh with regard well I I did discuss a
free trade agreement with India and both
the Prime Minister and I committed our
teams to working as quickly as we can to
see if we can bring a successful
conclusion to those negotiations uh with
regard to the US their priorities are in
lots of different areas but with regard
to trade with regard to trade what we
are doing and the president and I
discussed this we are deepening our
economic relationship the United States
has already our single largest trading
partner we're doing more with individual
states to broaden our trade uh trade
relationships and we've seen recent
action on tariffs with regard to Steel
aluminum and agricultural exports all of
which is good for the UK economy and and
of course we are in the process of some
exciting conversations about joining
cptpp that is real evidence of our
country's commitment to the indo-pacific
region is something that is supported by
the prime ministers of Canada Australia
and Japan and hopefully we can bring
those negotiations to conclusion in the
near future and lastly Mr Speaker I just
say that you know my Reflections on the
summit and indeed on attending copper
that the United Kingdom is at its best
when we are an Engaged and active member
of the global Community where we are
standing up for our values where we are
defending our interests but also
spreading prosperity and alleviating
poverty and suffering I'm I'm pleased
I'm pleased to have had conversations
with so many leaders over the past
couple of days it confirms to me that
they very much welcome the UK support in
achieving all of those objectives and
that's what this government will set
about doing
[Applause]
Alicia codes
dialogue is never weakness so will my
right on more friend tell us when he
intends to reschedule his meeting with
Xi Jinping because this is not an
endorsement of the Chinese Communist
party but an opportunity set forward are
red lines particularly in the Hostile
actions we've seen on UK saw in the last
month but we do also need to see shortly
a strategy from the Prime Minister on
China will he also inform the house what
progress is made at the G20 on isolating
Russia with India and other nations who
are not as aligned with us on Ukraine
because they are key to global stability
and also to ending bloodshed
well I thank the chair of the Foreign
Affairs Select Committee for her
excellent question she's absolutely
right about the importance of dialogue
she would have heard what I said to the
leader of the opposition we are in the
process of refreshing our integrated
review and no doubt our approach to
China will be a part of that but in the
meantime she's right that dialogue also
offers the opportunity for us to raise
issues of concern defending our values
and interests particularly uh with
regard to areas like Hong Kong which we
will continue to do as the opportunity
arises she's also right to point out the
position of those non-aligned countries
I think we should all take enormous
comfort from the fact that the G20
communique was actually agreed it was
substantive comprehensive and contained
strong language of condemnation about
Russia's aggression that was by no means
assured uh just a week or so ago and I
think speaks to the feeling in the
International Community something that I
saw across the G20 table as many if not
all almost all countries took the
opportunity to say some thing about
Russia's actions and join us in
condemning it but there is always work
to do and we will continue to have that
dialogue with those Partners we now come
to the leader of the SMP Ian Blackfoot
and thank you Mr Speaker and let me
thank the Prime Minister for advanced
site of his statement Mr Speaker with
the Russian military continued to find
deadly missiles at civilians right
across Ukraine I sincerely hope that
Putin's foreign minister was made to
feel the Justified anger and disgust by
those attending the G20 and with that in
mind can I begin by asking the Prime
Minister what progress has been made at
these Summits to further isolate Putin's
regime on the international stage the
whole world must stand together on
Russian sanctions and we must make sure
that those responsible for crimes
against humanity face Justice and what
progress has been made to ensure there
is no weakening in the international
resolve to stand with Ukraine until the
victory for their people
Mr Speaker in terms of G20 discussions
on the economy the Prime Minister and
the chancellor keep referring to the
global for ACT factors to blame for the
financial crisis facing families across
these islands it's the excuse that they
are using to impose austerity 2.0 in
today's financial statement but if this
is really all to do with global factors
can the Prime Minister explain why the
UK is the only G7 economy that is
smaller today than it was before the
pandemic why is the UK the only G7
country enacting austerity 2.0 the
reality is this is a political choice
and finally on the proposed indo-pacific
trade deal the latest brexit Forest Hill
that threatens to sell out our farmers
and Crafters not only this evidence
continues to mount that the brexit
effect to reduce our economy by four
percent a factory a factor that is
driving Tory austerity this week we
heard from the former deaf secretary who
retrospectively ripped apart the trade
deal with Australia and the damaging
impact it was have on a rugby food
sector a deal I would remind the
opposite benches endorsed by every
single conservative MP so can the Prime
Minister explain to Scotland's food and
farming Industries why are you so
committed to pursuing yet another brexit
deal which will deliver a hammer blow to
their businesses
[Music]
well miss
welcome the vulnerable gentleman's
comments about Russia and Ukraine thank
him for those I can he should be
reassured that the Russian foreign
minister felt I think the the Full
Assault of allies including the United
Kingdom in Putin's absence of the
absolute outrage that the crash and
International Community feels uh what is
happening and that will continue to do
so when Russia attend these fora uh with
regard to farming this government isn't
um absolute champion of British farming
and Farmers that will remain the case
and it will continue and it will
continue to find Opportunities to put
Great British produce on the tables of
many more families around the world and
that's what we will continue to do I'll
just briefly address his comments on the
economy because I I just point out I
mean he had a few different stats it's
worth bearing in mind that which has
come from a G20 Summit where two-thirds
of those G20 members sitting around that
table are experiencing inflation rates
north of seven percent
the IMF predicts that a third of the
world's economy is already or will
shortly be in recession and if he took
the time to read the uh G20 communique
he will see that actually the global uh
picture is very clear countries around
the world are grappling with high energy
prices High food prices and Rising
interest rates and indeed many countries
around the world like us have committed
as does the International Community to
ensuring fiscal sustainability as a path
to improving those that is absolutely
the challenge that we confront it's
absolutely the chat the challenge that
the chancellor will meet head on and we
will make those decisions with fairness
and with compassion so those defense
like committed to myself thank you Mr
Speaker could I strongly welcome the
prime minister's words at the G20 and
condemning Russia's aggression in
Ukraine I've just returned from Odessa
with the defense select committee where
there is huge appreciation for the
British efforts in supporting Ukraine at
this time
but just one-fifth of those grain ships
are able to get out compared with prior
to the war and with Russia's Maritime
Force severely diminished Odessa is
calling out for a new more efficient
grain deal
would the Prime Minister agree to meet
with me to look at securing a UN General
Assembly resolution bypassing the
security Council which would Grant
Odessa humanitarian Safe Haven status
and the formation of a un-led maritime
Force so there's vital grain ships can
be escorted safely out of Odessa
well my vulnerable friend is is right to
highlight the importance of the grain
shipments through Odessa I'm very
pleased that after concerted effort on
our part and other allies with the
United Nations Secretary General the
grain deal has indeed been extended
which was in some doubt just days ago I
think that demonstrates a pressure that
was put on Russia by the International
Community he knows the importance of the
free flow of both food and fertilizers
to the developing world through those
ships that I'd be delighted to meet with
him to see what more we could do but I
think for now we should we should be
very pleased that the grain deal is
being extended uh it's already seeing a
decline in wheat prices and that will
bring some alleviation to the food
inflation that we're seeing particularly
in the African continent Chris Brown Mr
Speaker Putin's aggression was allowed
to prosper for too long ever since 2008
You could argue so I completely support
what the Prime Minister has said and
done in supporting Ukraine against the
barbarism of the Russian Federation but
just on China can I ask him I understand
the real politique of this last week but
the the concentration camps in the
xinjiang province continue as does the
genocide and their suppression of human
rights in Hong Kong continues so can I
just ask him to do one thing which the
United States of America has already
done which has sanctioned Carrie Lam
B Deputy speaker I'm pleased that the
United Kingdom have led efforts to hold
China to account including imposing
sanctions on senior Chinese officials
and mobilizing international support to
hold China to account the United Nations
and as we heard previously we will use
dialogue as an opportunity to raise the
concerns we have on xinjiang and other
human rights abuses as we see them John
Barron thank you madam speaker I commend
the Prime Minister for the leadership
this country is providing across a range
of issues including Russia as to our
Ascension to the cptpp does he share my
enthusiasm and optimism given that this
is a trading block that represents
nearly 15 percent of the world's GDP and
it offers so many opportunities for so
many export Industries including the
scotch industry which terrorists would
fall from 100 in many cases to zero I'm
sure that is something even the SMP
could raise a glass to when we Joy
well my uh my honorable friend puts it
very very well and and he's right about
the importance of cptpp not only the
very significant economic benefits that
he mentions but also the Strategic
benefits about the United Kingdom being
an Engaged member of the indo-pacific
community as I said I discussed with the
prime ministers of uh Australia Japan
and Canada there's incredible excitement
about us joining and we'll continue to
conclude those negotiations as quickly
as possible
Liam blood thank you madam Deputy
speaker the Prime Minister will know
that the last G20 agreed to on lend a
hundred billion dollars of IMF special
drawing rights to help tackle the crisis
of food fragility and climate Finance in
the global South to date we have only
agreed to share much less of our
entitlement than both France and China
the crisis is now will the Prime
Minister look again at how we can
increase our on lending to this
multilateral effort not least to make
good for the appalling decision to slash
our Aid budget
so well Madam Deputy speaker I was
pleased as Chancellor to actually Usher
through the uh special drawing rights uh
allocation at the IMF which is providing
enormous relief to countries around the
world I met with the managing director
of the IMF to discuss how we can do more
but remember the SDR allocation is just
one part of our effort to support people
around the world also recently pleased
to announce a billion pound commitment
to the global fund something that was
warmly welcome especially by countries
in Africa
Jeffrey Clifton Brian a prime minister
to be congratulated on such successful
talks with so many leaders around the
world in particular with President Modi
could he update the house on other
matters other than trade he discussed
for example the granting of visas for
highly skilled people to fill those
needs in this country possibly on
environment but above all on the issue
erased by the Foreign Affairs committee
India's stance to supporting Ukraine as
the world's biggest democracy
um well my uh my friend is is absolutely
right our our relationship and
partnership with India goes so much more
broad broadly than uh than just the
trading relationship actually I was
pleased to discuss increasing our
security cooperation with India work
that has began before my tenure but
we're keen to carry on and also we made
an announcement on a Mobility scheme for
young people both from India to come
here and for Brits to go there it's a
sign of what is possible and I think
those types of exchanges are both
positive for countries involved and for
the young people who will benefit from
them
speaker at the G20 the Prime Minister
agreed with his Indian counterpart to
allow an additional 3 000 Indians into
the UK every year which inevitably in
the fullness of time will lead to an
increase in Immigration but at the same
time the Home Secretary has been busy
spouting anti-immigrant anti-refugee dog
whistle rhetoric including incendiary
remarks against International Indian
students which so incensed people within
India so uh who exactly is in charge of
immigration policy is it the prime
minister or the wannabe prime minister
well Madam please I'm disappointed with
the honorable honorable Gentiles
comments because I know
I think he can actually take comfort
from the announcement that we just made
which is good also for Indian students
as well as it is for British students to
be able to go back and forth that is a
good thing and what the Home Secretary
is rightly focused on uh and and nothing
dog whistle about it is clamping down on
illegal migration
the British people rightly expect and
demand and it's something that the Home
Secretary and this government will
deliver
Republicans thank you madam Deputy
speaker the leader of the opposition
said correctly Russia is losing this war
and like a wounded animal it is lashing
out using weapons now we believe from
Iran and also from North Korea was any
consideration given to additional
sanctions on those two countries and
also possibly excluding Russia from
membership of the G20
my um I say to my honorable friend you
know the G20 is not like the G7 it's a
broader grouping of countries that works
by consensus so it is not possible to
expel Russia in the same way but what he
will take comfort from is that we use
the opportunity to unequivocally condemn
Russia's actions with regard to
sanctions on Iran and others uh he he
will know or may be aware that we have
recently imposed new sanctions on Iran
but related specifically to their
treatment of protesters in the recent
demonstrations it's the right thing to
do the behavior of the Iranian regime is
not acceptable and we should hold them
to account for it
Hilary back thank you very much indeed
Madam Deputy speaker facing the worst
drought in 40 years tens of millions of
people in East Africa are going hungry
children are dying today of malnutrition
and the United Nations expects a famine
to be declared before the end of the
year while recognizing the humanitarian
Aid that the UK has already given does
the Prime Minister recognize that the
International Community now needs to do
more to save lives and not wait for that
formal Declaration of family
Deputy speaker the UK is already
tackling this issue head on at Unger we
announced funding in particular for
famine support in Somalia and our work
on helping to secure an extension to the
Black Sea grain initiative will make an
enormous difference to the people that
he rightly cares about as do I uh but
I'd also let him know that countries in
Africa were very pleased by our
commitment to the global fund because
they know that will also help alleviate
some of the the difficulties that
they're facing
Siobhan Bailey
Global pressures and threats not least
in protecting the people of Ukraine but
despite Twitter mainly having a meltdown
over flowery shirts as this was his
first G20 as prime minister can my right
honorable friend tell us how useful he
found the meeting for relationship
building in consolidating joint
International working
uh well I could say to my uh honorable
friend of course these these Summits are
helpful in coordinating Global action on
tackling challenges like inflation or
indeed supporting Ukraine uh but it's
also helpful in building those
relationships with foreign leaders that
can deliver tangible benefit for people
here at home most recently we've seen
that given the dialogue we are now
having with President macron the French
that's led to a New Deal to help us
tackle illegal migration that's an
example of why these dialogues and
Summits matter but it's delivering real
change for people here at home
Ben Bradshaw thank you madam Deputy
speaker and further to his replies about
our relationship with India why are
britons alone in Europe currently
excluded from the Indian e-visa scheme
which is doing more damage to our
hard-pressed travel and tourism sector
and extreme inconvenience for British
families who want to visit relatives in
India in the months to come did his
discussions with Prime Minister Modi
give many hope that this ban might be
lifted anytime soon I can tell my
honorable it's something that we
discussed and raised of course I would
like to see the United Kingdom included
on the e-visa scheme and he can rest
assured that we'll continue to raise it
with our Indian counterparts
foreign
friend confirm that in his conversations
with President Biden of the U.S and his
counterparts in the EU he has made it
absolutely clear the UK's intention to
preserve the Integrity of the Good
Friday agreement and would you also
confirm that in so doing it is not
unreasonable for the UK an independent
and Sovereign Nation to be able to
maintain its own economic integrity
I I can give my writable friend that
Assurance of course the territorial
Integrity of the United Kingdom is
important and must be preserved and that
is under some stress as we have seen in
Northern Ireland that he knows uh very
well from his previous role uh and he
has my commitment to the Good Friday
agreement something that I discussed not
only with our European counterparts but
also the president we remain committed
to develop delivering all strands of
that agreement and that's what I will
work tirelessly to do
Patrick Grady speaker were there any
discussions at the G20 about the
situation in Iran I've heard from a lot
of constituents who want to express
their solidarity with the protesters and
their outrage that the way the regime is
cracking down on them so what steps can
the G20 take to support progress towards
stability and democracy in Iran
well the protests send a clear message
that the Iranian people are not
satisfied uh with the path that their
government has taken as I was mentioning
uh we have now sanctioned 24 extra
people both political and security
officials for their role in the
Crackdown on protesters and my honorable
friend the foreign secretary recently
summoned uh Iran's most senior Diplomat
in the UK to make clear that we do not
tolerate threats to life and
intimidation of any kind
Mr Speaker does my right honorable
friend agree that Putin was emboldened
to attack Ukraine by The Continuous
appeasement of Western democracies over
many years and why does he not think
that a similar appeasement of the
Chinese dictatorship will not result in
a similar disaster
so I I just say to my honorable friend
that our approach to China is in
complete alignment with the United
States with Canada on Australia it is
one that is absolutely clear-eyed about
the challenges that China uh poses to
our values and to our interests into our
Economic Security and that's why it's
right that we take robust action to
defend ourselves against that as we saw
just yesterday with a decision on
Chinese investment in a sensitive
industry in this country
thank you madam Deputy speaker one of
the key Global challenges facing the G20
is migration and refugees and I know
this country has a proud history of
fulfilling our International obligations
to the most vulnerable including
children so could the Prime Minister uh
just confirm that no unaccompanied
Asylum seeking children under the age of
eight are currently being held at
manston and if he doesn't know the
answer could he write to me as a matter
of urgency
I've been happy to write to a honorable
lady at she'll know well that we have
different processes and procedures in
place for unaccompanied Asylum seeking
children to make sure that they get
Extra safeguarding Protection as they
rightly are due and I'll get back to her
with an update on where we are
Robbie Moore thank you madam Deputy
speaker Russian attacks on Ukrainian
energy infrastructure in recent weeks
just show the full extent of Putin's
complete desperation so can the Prime
Minister confirm that the UK is
providing Ukraine with the energy
equipment and the support that they need
to help repair their infrastructure so
that they can keep their lights on and
their heat coming in the months ahead
my uh my honorable friend is absolutely
right to raise this particular need of
the ukrainians it's something that I've
discussed a couple of times with
president zielinski and I can restore
him in the house that we are playing our
part in providing funding and expertise
to help resolve some of the issues and
the ukrainians I know are very grateful
for that support
Caroline Lucas thank you madam Deputy
speaker the G20 communique urged all
parties to finalize and adopt the
forthcoming cop 15 Global biodiversity
framework in Montreal at this crisis
time for nature both globally and at
home he'll know the importance of
leading by example so as well as
accelerating the UK's domestic
environment
environmental agenda will he ensure that
he is not forced into another last
minute U-turn as we saw ahead of cop26
will he commit now to attending cop15 in
person and show that leadership
well Madam Deputy speak I don't think
anyone can doubt our commitment to
biodiversity in nature it was something
that the ukulele Kingdom proudly LED at
at Glasgow last year to put it on the
agenda will have a range of different
people attending Montreal but I was very
pleased that we ensured that the G20
communique reaffirmed the g20's
commitment to the targets that were set
at cop that was something that we fought
very hard for and we should all rightly
be proud that it is there in the G20
community okay
speaker can I ask the premise a specific
question with regards to the
conversation he had with prime minister
tudo the United Kingdom and Canada have
a specifically close relationship by
being members of the G7 G20 five eyes
NATO and the Commonwealth whether it's
friendships in Parliament or whether
it's friendships work with world leaders
one needs to know where they stand can
ask the Prime Minister did he asked
Prime statuto with regards to Canada
stepping up to its two percent GDP
towards NATO and did the United Kingdom
ask Canada to do more in the high North
the Arctic where we Face greater threat
from Russia and they have a specific
expertise in that area
well uh Madam Deputy speaker I encourage
all members of NATO to make their way
towards the two percent Target something
that we've proudly done uh in this
country for some years uh but also our
cooperation with Canada is deep uh prime
minister Trudeau was pleased to announce
an extension of the Canadian support for
our program to train Ukrainian uh
soldiers here something that we're
working closely with them on and I'd be
happy to pick up the conversation on the
high North again that will be a feature
of our refreshed integrated review
Grant Davis
the Prime Minister knows that the energy
Charter treaty enables fossil fuel
companies to sue governments who pass
legislation that undermine their future
profits in the name of climate change
and which is why Germany and France have
announced their withdrawing as a Poland
Holland Sylvania and Spain so when does
he anticipate in the UK withdrawing from
the energy Charter treaty or does he put
fossil fuel profits ahead of climate
change and will he brace this within WTO
reform
well I The Honorable gentleman mentioned
a range of other countries in regard to
fossil fuels actually it was United
Kingdom who led through the cop last
year and making sure that we end uh the
climate Finance for coal plants uh
something that actually other countries
do need to catch up with us on and we
will continue to Champion that in all
these forums because that's the right
thing to do and it was a commitment we
made at Glasgow that needs to be upheld
Richard Drex
Madam deaf speaker having just returned
from Ukraine myself with the defense
committee along with my right on my
friend can I tell the house how movingly
grateful they are to all the support we
give and in particular to our right
humble friend for his outstanding
leadership of this country uh fighting
this Russian aggression however there
are shortages of food ammunition and
miniature equipment and while we in the
United States are doing our bit there is
concern other countries are not Cameron
formed the house
during the g19 or G20 meeting did he
have any feedback from other countries
that they're going to step up to the
plate like ourselves and the Americans
to do
um well my honorable friend is
absolutely right about the need to
continue supporting Ukraine for as long
as it takes that that remains a feature
of all our conversations with allies
there's lots of different ways people
can play their part for example as I
mentioned the Canadians recently
extending their support for training
ukrainians here but he's right that we
need to keep up the pressure the UK has
shown great leadership on this alongside
America and we will jointly encourage
others to follow our lead and make sure
that Ukraine can be in the strongest
possible position for bringing an end to
this awful conflict Daisy Cooper I'm
Deputy speaker does the Prime Minister
agree with me that private citizens in
the UK should follow the example of
several British businesses and sell any
shares that they have in businesses that
still operate in Russia
well Madam Deputy speaker the United
Kingdom took the lead in imposing some
of the most stringent sanctions uh
economic sanctions on both the Russian
economy Russian businesses and indeed
Russian individuals uh it's pleasing
that other countries have followed and
we will continue to push other countries
to follow our lead with sanctions and we
will continue to tighten them where we
think it can make a difference
Stephen Hammond just a question thank
you Deputy speaker can I take my right
honorable friend for his update on trade
talks can I ask him whether in those
talks there was any discussion about
extending the arrangements to include
our number one industry finance and
Professional Services in those
arrangements yeah actually my honorable
friend knows this area well and that's
why it's important that we take the time
with trade deals because often Services
liberalization which he rightly knows is
very important for our economy does take
longer to negotiate than simple tariff
Productions on Goods our economy has an
incredible Services sector it's
important that they benefit from trade
deals going forward and that's what I'm
want to make sure it happens very
Gardner thank you
when the Prime Minister met with Crown
Prince Mohammed bin Salman earlier this
week did he challenge him on the way in
which Saudi Arabia has been blocking the
proposal at cop 27 for the phase down of
all fossil fuels
Madam Deputy speaker we had a wide
raging conversation on a range of topics
including climate change we have very
much committed to our obligations under
the cop agreement and we very much
welcome Saudi Arabia's commitment to be
Net Zero by 2060 there's lots of
different opportunities for them to play
their part as cop presidents coming up
and we will look forward to supporting
them in that endeavor
Ruth Edwards
and the last few years have shown us the
importance of resilient Supply chains
can my honorable my honorable friend
confirm that a priority for his
discussions with allies at the G20 was
decoupling Art Supply chains from
authoritarian regimes in key areas such
as critical minerals and products like
semiconductors
yeah my honorable friend makes an
excellent point and I'm pleased to tell
her that just yesterday the business
secretary made a decision with regard to
semiconductors which should give her and
others confidence that we take this
incredibly seriously I discuss critical
minerals with many of our allies around
the world and I'm pleased to say that
Japan with their G7 presidency next year
will put Economic Security at the heart
of our Collective agenda
Kevin Brennan
Deputy speaker on Northern Ireland it's
reported today in the times that the
Prime Minister promised President Biden
that the issues surrounding the Northern
Ireland protocol would be sold by next
April was that a commitment that he gave
to President Biden and with a long hard
winter facing the people of Northern
Ireland without a government there in
place shouldn't there be a greater sense
of urgency from the UK government to
sort this out yeah well a Madam Deputy
speaker as I've said actually publicly
and clearly I want to see a resolution
to this issue as soon as possible it's
why I spoke to my counterparts in
Ireland the European commission and
others almost the first day I took
office and I'm working very hard to try
and bring about a negotiated settlement
to the challenges we face but those
challenges on the ground are real
businesses families communities are
suffering as a result of the protocol
I've made that point loudly and clearly
to all our counterparts and I've urged
them to show flexibility and pragmatism
in their response so we can get the
situation resolved on the ground and get
the executive back up and running
because that's what the people of
Northern Ireland deserve
Richard Graham
Madam Deputy speaker I congratulate G20
in its chair on their final communique
with unanimous condemnation of the
continued invasion of Ukraine and the
Prime Minister and other Western leaders
on their work to de-escalate tensions
between the west and China would my
right honorable friend agree with me
that apart from the important work that
he is doing multilaterally in the TPP
and bilaterally with India on the FDA
there are also other bilateral
opportunities with leading Asian
countries and when he encouraged their
heads of government to do working visits
to the UK
I I actually will do that and can I also
congratulate my honorable friend on his
reappointment as a trade-in boy to
Indonesia it's a region he knows
particularly well and he's done
fantastic work in deepening our
bilateral relationship with a country
that is going to play an increasingly
important role in the global economy uh
the one of the the third largest
democracy in the world one of the
largest Muslim countries in the world
and will soon to be a top five economy
it's right that we have relationships
within Indonesia and I thank him for his
part and making sure that that is
happening
I'm Deputy speaker water and sanitation
is a major Global crisis causing
conflict migration equality for women
and girls and health outcomes which are
easily preventable can the Prime
Minister confirm whether he had
conversations about the water and
sanitation crisis with other G20 members
and will he reverse the 80 percent fcdo
cuts to water and sanitation projects
uh well Madam Deputy speaker the
conversations I have with other leaders
were incredibly appreciative of the role
that the United Kingdom is playing in
helping to tackle uh suffering poverty
and poor sanitation around the world and
particularly what was highlighted was
our recent commitment of a billion
pounds to the global fund as well as our
track record and supporting countries to
alleviate famine those are things that
everyone in this house should be proud
of and this government will continue to
Champion
thank you madam Deputy speaker the whole
house will welcome the shared commitment
to the defense of Ukraine and the rule
of law but my right honorable friend
will know that key to that last element
is the work of the international
criminal court which launched its
investigation into war crimes in March
with an aspiration to issue an
indictment by the end of the year can he
confirm that the UK will continue to do
all it can to support their work
including the difficult task that lies
ahead of obtaining custody of Russian
military generals to stand trial
uh well obviously this is the narrow
mindable friend though as well and she's
right to highlight it I'm pleased to
tell her the United Kingdom was out in
front in providing both Technical and
financial resources to the efforts to
gather the evidence and I know uh the
Justice secretary is in touch with the
British prosecutor as well and the team
will have our full support
I'll listen to you
the case of a jagger Singh johal who
today has been held in arbitious
detention for
1840 days the Sikh community in Scotland
are incredibly concerned about this
situation so it wasn't just hand seeks
and Instagram photographs or did he
raise this case yeah yeah
mounted deputy said we've consistently
raised our concerns about Mr johal's
Case directly with all levels of the
Indian government I discussed more
generally the issues around extradition
with Prime Minister Modi and the foreign
secretary raised this case with India's
minister of external Affairs just last
month on his visit to India
it's okay Mr Miku
it's made reference to the dangers of
death traps for emerging economies can
he give further information on what
steps the United Kingdom has taken to
provide emerging economies with
alternatives to Chinese money
well my honorable friend is right to
highlight the need for sensible
Alternatives we tend to work not just by
Lottery but also multilaterally through
things like SDR recycling at the IMF at
the new resilience and sustainability
trust that was established was done so
with UK leadership and indeed the new
debt service suspension initiative is
something that I championed as
Chancellor and we need to make sure that
we deliver on it
Toby Perkins who very much modern Deputy
speaker the prime minister laid out his
uh approach to trade deals in his State
uh did well he will be aware that while
he was there the right honorable member
for Camborne and Red Roof was describing
the trade deal with Australia is not a
very good deal for the United Kingdom
does the Prime Minister agree with uh
the right angle member who formerly the
environment section if so what's he
going to do about it yeah yeah for the
Prime Minister attempts to answer the
questions too much noise in the chamber
yeah I mean you would think that people
were anticipating something happening
and chatting amongst themselves instead
of giving their full attention to the
important answers the prime minister is
giving to important questions
prime minister
thank you madam Deputy speaker maybe not
as important as what's about to come
from the chancellor but all trade deals
uh involve give or take on both sides
the Australia trade deal will open up
new markets for three million British
jobs which is fantastic reduce prices
for Australian goods and make it easier
for young people to move back and forth
between those two countries and going
forward we will ensure that our trade
deals work for the UK that's what we'll
deliver
Rob Butler thank you madam Deputy
speaker the Prime Minister has
reaffirmed the government's strong
commitment to supporting Ukraine in the
face of Russia's illegal and inhumane
Invasion and underlined the leadership
that we provided to other countries can
he confirm that our superb Armed Forces
will continue to provide the appropriate
support especially in training Ukraine's
Brave Defenders to ensure that evil
cannot Triumph the Putin fails and did
he encourage other G20 members to do
likewise
you know my own reference makes an
excellent point and it's an issue that
he's rightly championed on previous
occasions I can give him that
reassurance
the NATO Secretary General was just in
the United Kingdom uh days ago visiting
the training that we're providing for
Ukrainian soldiers it's something that
is looked at favorably by many allies
around the world which is why prime
minister Trudeau was pleased to confirm
when he was with me an extension to
Canadian support for that program and
hopefully many more countries will
follow
Tony Lloyd
speaker is it's not so many months ago
that any International Conference like
the G20 would have been seized with the
situation in Afghanistan
Afghanistan has now gone off the agenda
but the humanitarian crisis there is one
that is moving into absolute tragedies
people are facing starvation can the
Prime Minister tell us what
conversations did take place about
Afghanistan or in any case will he now
reconvene the kind of donor conference
that could make a material difference
starvation in that country
my uh my honorable friend is right to
highlight that Afghanistan continues to
experience one of the world's worst
humanitarian crises uh that's why
earlier this year we co-hosted uh un
pledging Summit together with Germany
and Qatar that helped raise over two
billion dollars for Afghanistan uh but
he's he's right to put it on the agenda
I'll make sure that we continue to do
what we can to support the people there
it's about black man thank you madam
Deputy speaker a free trade deal with
India is a tremendous opportunity for
both the United Kingdom and India and I
agree with my right or friend we should
not sacrifice quality at the expense of
doing a deal quickly however during his
discussions with prime minister Narendra
Modi what obstacles to actually clear so
that we can actually get on with the
free trade deal that we all want to see
no well I know my honorable friend has
rightly been a significant champion of
this deal and our relationships with
with India I'm pleased to have his
support uh now without negotiating for
all these things in public I'm pleased
that the majority of the substantive
negotiations conversations were
concluded uh by the end of October we
will now work at PACE with the Indian
teams to try and resolve the issues and
come to a mutually satisfactory
conclusion we're a hobhouse
our closest trading partners are still
in the EU can you update us what he did
during the G20 Summit to improve
relationship with EU countries which to
say the least are still fragile since
brexit
uh well uh Mr Deputy speaker we may we
may have left the EU but we have not
left Europe and it's important that we
maintain strong and positive
relationships with our European partners
and allies that's very much uh what I
intend to do and I'm pleased that those
conversations have been going well
very much Mr Speaker I'm glad that the
situation regarding refugees all over
the world was discussed but no debate on
refugees can be complete without a
discussion about the plight of the
rohingya
um could my rights have been confirmed
to me that world leaders considered and
had a discussion about further support
we can provide to rohingya refugees who
a large refugee camp in the world and
one of great concern for my constituents
well I I know this is an issue of
concern for my honorable friend and it's
right that he raises it and champions
the case I'm pleased to tell him that we
have sanctioned those people responsible
and we will continue to make sure that
we can provide whatever support we can
to the people who need our help John
Trickett grateful uh Mr Speaker
in the communique from the G20 the woods
food food supply our food food scarcity
you mentioned 54 separate times
and it's good that Britain's taking part
of a global community's fight to make
sure that food is properly distributed
but last year before the Ukraine war one
in nine britons were driven to use a
Food Bank
isn't it clear it wasn't disruption of
food which is a problem it was poverty
poverty driven by number 10 and number
11 when he was in the when he was in the
treasury and isn't it clear that for the
poor of Britain
this is a nightmare
holder is a nightmare created by Downing
Street
[Applause]
[Music]
well I
uh the speaker the chancellor is about
to deliver a statement that's going to
ensure that our economy is strong that
we support the most vulnerable and we
have a clear platform for growth I know
it's the honorable gentleman to wait for
it
good job you Mr Speaker peace on the
continent must be restored it's a fact
that no one in Europe is truly safe
until Putin fails can my right honorable
friend update the house on how we'll
make this happen alongside our Global
allies in the G20
[Music]
well uh Mr Speaker what's important is
that Russia understands that the global
Community speaks with one voice in
condemning its illegal and barbaric
actions I'm pleased that the G20
communique expresses that sentiment as
many more countries are joining our
efforts to stand up to Russian
aggression and support Ukraine
the speaker during talks on the cptpp
the Define Minister conveyed the
concerns of the UK's fantastic foods and
farming Industries and what assurances
was he able to have seen that these
industries will be consider to
unprotected as negotiations continue
well Mr Speaker I stand by our
commitment not to compromise the United
Kingdom's High environmental animal
welfare and food safety standards and
will ensure that our trade deals open up
new markets for British Farmers to look
cabins the cost of living in the UK is
going up mainly because of the war that
Russia is purporting but it's not just
affecting us it's affecting the EU Zone
which has inflation as an average of 10
percent so what discussions did the
Prime Minister have about the strategy
of the G20 to deal with inflation which
is clearly a worldwide problem
uh not my honorable friend is absolutely
right to highlight the global nature of
these challenges that we are facing in
part caused uh by Russia's aggression uh
the G20 communique is clear on
responsibility of individual countries
to ensure Financial stability and as it
says that means delivering long-term
fiscal sustainability and that's what
this Chancellor will deliver Jim Shannon
I'm not just speaker can I thank the
Prime Minister very much for the
statement and for a strong startup
behalf of the United Kingdom of Great
Britain and Northern Ireland we thank
you for that the actions of Putin under
his regime have driven two-thirds of the
G20 countries and the economic distress
raised inflation for us in this country
by 10 to 11 and talk about recession are
prevalent for many countries Russia is
the Enemy Within in the G20 what does
the Prime Minister doing to align with
all other g-cuddy countries the
ostracized Russia and to reduce their
influence and indeed if possible their
very membership of the G20
well uh Mr Speaker it is not possible in
a consensual organization to expel
Russia but I'm pleased to say to The
Honorable gentleman that we work closely
with all Partners across the G20 to
deliver a strong unified message that
the threatened use of nuclear weapons is
inadmissible and today's era must not be
the era for War I think Russia heard
that message loud and clear Aaron Bell
thank you Mr Speaker I share my right
honorable friends with you that China
presents a systemic challenge to the
West we've just seen in Russia how an
authoritarian action can use their role
in our supply chains to do damage to the
global economy so can my right honorable
friend confirm that when we do engage
with China on global issues like climate
change or public health he'll never do
so at the expense of our national or
Economic Security
I can absolutely give my honorable
friend that Assurance we will always be
robust in defending our values and our
interests and that starts with our
national security
speaker
[Music]
thank you very much so
um the government's mishandling of the
Northern Ireland protocol negotiations
is acting as a barrier to trade deals
and to Scientific collaboration the
Prime Minister says he was much
influenced by his time at Stamford
surely he understands the key role of
Science and scientific research in
driving economic growth something we
solely need at the moment is he really
going to exclude British scientists from
the world's biggest scientific research
program Horizon prime minister I think
Mr Speaker no one can doubt my
commitment personally to ensuring that
the UK remains as it is a science a
scientific and technological superpower
that's why we've increased the r d
budget that's why we're deregulating to
support Innovation that's why we're
reforming our Capital markets to get
money to all the companies who need it
we'll hear more from the chancellor
about that but I can give the honorable
lady every Assurance Innovation is the
way we drive growth and that's what the
government will deliver that completes
the statement on the G20 before we come
to the statement by the chancellor of
the exchequer I'd like to point out that
the British sign language interpretation
of the statement and opposition from
bench's responses will be available to
watch on Parliament live TV I know call
the chancellor of the extracted to make
a statement
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Mr Speaker
in the face of unprecedented Global
headwinds families pensioners businesses
teachers nurses and many others are
worried about the future so today we
deliver a plan to tackle the cost of
living crisis and rebuild our economy